[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily sentencing for
the man known as the norcal rapist
10 assaults over two decades how
detectives caught this serial offender
the answer has always been in the dna
and a former political candidate accused
of kidnapping a 12-year-old
across state lines the girl now saved
home the suspect
in jail to save this little girl from
unimaginable assaults the search
continues for missing three-year-old
nilo
how prosecutors are going after his
mother's accused killer
plus activists take to the streets over
the treatment of immigrant detainees in
custody
we speak with the defense attorney
representing protesters who found
themselves behind bars
[Music]
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmart
along with terry austin the infamous
norcal rapist was sentenced to nearly
900 years
behind bars
roy waller was convicted of a 15-year
crimes plea that included raping nine
women in six
different cities prosecutors say he
terrorized northern california
between 1991 and 2006. genetic genealogy
cracked the case in 2018
using similar techniques to those in the
golden state killer case
the nine women testified at his trial
and detectives say he used a similar
motive
during the attacks the victims in this
case can stop looking over their
shoulders
no one else has to worry about this
happening to them
and they are truly the victims in this
case
uh the strongest people i know and the
bravest people i know
he would enter houses
uh usually late at night sometimes the
victims would be asleep
sometimes they would be going about
their activities in the evening
he would overcome them he would
find them and then repeatedly sexually
assault them he would ransack their
homes
and sometimes he would kidnap the
victims and take them to atms where
he would get money out of their accounts
and other times he would steal personal
items from their homes
at trial the jury deliberated for less
than three hours
convicting him of 46 charges including
kidnapping
forcible rape and sodomy
ten years after the attack in contra
costa county
our office filed a john doe complaint
with the specific
dna profile of this same individual
with the complaint there was a john doe
warrant for five hundred
thousand dollars we filed a complaint to
preserve
the statute of limitations for some of
the counts
in this case a total of twelve felony
counts were included
in the complaint joining me is attorney
terry austin
terry the judge took a 459 year sentence
and ran it consecutively to a 438 to
life sentence
what kind of message do you think the
judge was sending
a very clear message brian i mean that's
a total of
897 years and that was for 46 counts so
the judge
actually gave the maximum amount on
each count and he was trying to say
these are very
heinous crimes and i want to make sure
that this defendant
serves as many years as possible under
the law and then i guess the following
question terry is is this the proper
sentence in your eyes
you know i know there will be some who
are arguing this wasn't a murder case so
why must it be so long but in my opinion
i think the nature of the crime
deserves this type of punishment so yes
i think it was correct
gotcha terry an update in the college
admissions scandal terry austin has the
latest
on how the famous couple is doing during
their sentence
brian actress lori laughlin and her
husband designer massimo gianouli
are both imprisoned but giannuli is
reportedly under
tight conditions sources tell people
magazine that the designer has been
placed in protective custody
for his five-month prison sentence it's
apparently out of an abundance of
caution for covet 19 protocols
his son posted on instagram saying that
his father has been locked in solitary
confinement
for one full month and is only let out
every three days to shower
the couple pleaded guilty to bribing
college officials
to get their two daughters into the
university of southern california
laughlin is expected to be released at
the end of december
brian thanks terry a former virginia
delegate candidate is in custody for
allegedly kidnapping
a 12-year-old girl he met online nathan
larson is being held in a colorado jail
on charges of child abducting soliciting
child pornography
and meeting a child for the intention of
sex the girl's family reported her
missing in fresno california
on december 14th detective learned she
met larson on social media
and had boarded a plane with him bound
for washington d.c
authorities intercepted them on a
layover in denver
larson flew to fresno from virginia and
then traveled to the girl's home
he persuaded her to sneak out of her
house at around two in the morning
he used a ride share company to pick her
up and together
they rode to the fresno airport larson
made her wear a long
hair wig to alter her appearance and
make her look older
he also told her to act as though she
was disabled
and unable to speak to ensure she would
not converse with anyone at the airport
while making their way onto the airplane
detectives uncovered nathan larson has a
deeply
disturbing background he is a white
supremacist
and a well-known advocate for pedophilia
this is a man who runs a website which
encourages the raping of children
and sharing of naked photos and video of
children
being raped terry the
allegations alone are horrendous enough
but you like you heard there
white supremacist runs a website that
advocates for
the sexual abuse of children it sounds
like the judge or the court at least is
going to throw the book at this guy what
do you think
i do think they will throw the book at
him i mean you heard sheriff mims there
talking about the fact
you know it was kidnapping child
abduction and he was trying to
meet a child for purposes of sex so i
think these are obviously
very heinous crimes i think they want to
make sure that they
put this to an end he had this website
going
and in fact ryan he was running for
office under this
platform so people knew about what
he was standing for and i think they
definitely will throw the book at him
now tara based on the nature of the
crime and how they they believe that he
he groomed these girls there could be
other unreported victims do you think
there could be more
victims down the line absolutely this is
widespread you heard
the sheriff saying it there and i do
think there will be other victims
thank you terry still ahead of law and
crime daily police arrest people
protesting the conditions of immigration
immigrants in custody
and later on the saga of the doomsday
cult mom continues
laurie vallo's latest motion what you
need to know after this
tensions are rising in new jersey where
protests over immigration and custom
enforcement
have resulted in nine arrests protesters
have been in more than a month-long
standoff with jail
administrations fighting to release
immigrant detainees
due to the pandemic according to reports
some detainees have been on a hunger
strike
because of the unsafe conditions inside
the bergen county jail
the sheriff says reports of rat
infestation and unsafe drinking water
are
untrue and is calling for protesters to
remain peaceful
the gathering became increasingly unruly
and as some
protesters hopped over the barricades
and began trespassing onto the jail
property
multiple requests by officers to vacate
the property were ignored
despite efforts to de-escalate the
situations
protesters continued their resistance
moving barricades
throwing bricks spitting spraying
officers
with pepper spray and even biting two
officers
i want to reinforce that this is only
applies to some individuals and that
many
were there to protest peacefully and
respectively
joining me now is jamie santana junior
criminal defense and civil rights
attorney
representing some of the protesters
jamie thank you for joining us
thank you very much brian my pleasure
now now jamie generally what can you
tell us about your clients
and what went down during that day of
protests and arrests
brian what you're beginning to
experience more and more is essentially
an outrage there's an outrage going on
because of the deplorable conditions
that exist within these facilities not
just bergen county facilities but
facilities throughout new jersey
new york as well in fact many facilities
across the country and so you've seen a
lot of these protesters
they're outraged and they simply can't
take it anymore
now i know you're representing some of
the protesters that were arrested
how is that going for those protesters
who are fighting
for what we're seeing here on our screen
and what you just told us
brian these protesters are not going to
stop they're out there every single day
and essentially they're protesting
not only because of the deplorable
conditions but many of these detainees
are being detained for an
indefinite period of time without proper
access to legal representation
uh these families are frustrated you're
talking about loved ones who have been
detained for
a significant period of time and this
has just gotten way out of control brian
and what's going on with those who are
detained are there cases being heard
are the protests may be making the
process move
move along so that these these cases can
be heard and maybe they get released
well brian generally speaking what's
supposed to happen is when you become
detained or when you're detained you're
supposed to generally see
speaking see a judge with respect to a
bond hearing within
may one maybe two weeks but essentially
the
uh detention process is an
administrative process it's not a
criminal process
it's an administrative civil process and
these detention facilities essentially
they're oftentimes deeming these
detainees to be a flight risk
and so they're not eligible for bond the
problem
here is the motive behind why these
detainees
are being denied bond and the motive
comes down to one word brian
and that's money so i guess what's the
solution here for those who are detained
as well as your clients who have now
find themselves arrested for protesting
those detainees
well essentially what these detainees
their families and these protesters are
seeking is they're seeking
a complete cancellation of the contract
between
the ice detention facilities and the
respective counties essentially brian
what happens is
ice pays counties a significant amount
of money
well into the millions upon millions of
dollars to essentially
house these detainees so certainly there
is an incentive for these
counties to continue with these
contracts because if they cancel them
essentially
they'll be losing a significant amount
of profit profiting essentially from the
criminalization of poverty
and lack of citizenship in these cases
sounds like a real civil rights issue
here you're talking about
basically people being detained for the
purpose of funds
and i get that's why the protest is
going on i want to keep
following up there with the protesters
what kind of charges are they facing and
how's that fight in court
for those who are arrested after the
protest
brian the clients that continue to
contact being charged with anywhere from
small misdemeanor fences
um all the way up to serious felony
offenses
and these offenses can certainly leave
them with criminal records
serious criminal records but they're no
longer just sitting back and accepting
uh this criminalization of poverty
they're beginning to reach out
more and more and more and saying listen
we want
uh zealous inadequate representation on
our cases we're not going to stand for
this
they are adamant about seeking out their
civil rights and and rightfully so
brian jamie i want to thank you very
much for joining us today and continue
to fight that good fight in new jersey
as well
as new york city thank you brian it's
been a pleasure thank you for having me
coming up on law on crime daily a utah
mother accused of shooting her
two-year-old son
and driving around with his body for
hours but first
hear how a mother stood up to her
daughter's killer her impactful words
next
[Music]
welcome back the list of demands from
the defense of the so-called doomsday
cult mom
is growing terry austin has the latest
motion filed in the case
brian the defense attorney for lori
vallo is requesting a list of
any person that the prosecution has
spoken to in the case valo
and her husband chad dabell are charged
with concealing evidence related to the
deaths of valo's two children
the bodies of seven-year-old joshua j.j
valo and 16 year old
tylie ryan were found on day bell's
property a recording of the call that
prosecutor rob
wood had with valo's sister made its way
to the defense
the defense is accusing wood of witness
intimidation
and want him removed from the case wood
filed an affidavit
saying that the interviews were quote
introductory in nature and not
investigative a closed door hearing was
held on the matter
and the outcome is not yet public brian
thanks terry the mother of a murder
victim let her killer know exactly how
she feels
long crime founder and host of the tv
series court camp
has a powerful impact statement
we're back in the kent county courthouse
for the sentencing of jared chance
he's been convicted in the gruesome
killing of ashley young
this was an extremely disturbing
set of facts and circumstances
where you killed and dismembered this
young lady ashley young
only ashley was studying to earn her
college degree
and had previously worked in a nursing
home the night ashley was killed
she was reconnecting with chants at a
local bar
only her torso was found in the basement
the police although they did an
excellent job
in this matter working every possible
lead
could never find ashley's head
her hands or her feet
today judge mark trusock will deliver
his sentence
but first ashley young's mother
christine will get the opportunity to
deliver a victim impact statement
directly to the killer i thought i would
be able
to write this with all the things that i
wanted to say
but i have such a hard time
concentrating
now i cry seven days
a week saying
i do not sleep well
my mind never stops never
a key time to live every moment
we had together actually i
miss you every moment of every
[Music]
you have no right to take her from me
to take her from her family
chance was sentenced to 100 to 200 years
in prison
for second murder and dismembering a
body
when we come back rescuers continue to
search for a missing three-year-old boy
in ohio
his mother's boyfriend now indicted with
her murder how the criminal prosecution
is moving forward
next
[Music]
a utah mother is accused of shooting her
two-year-old son
then turning the gun on herself and
surviving
valerie peck is facing charges of
aggravated murder and child abuse
the unita county sheriff's office says
peck drove her son
to a camping area and shot him with a 22
caliber rifle
she then apparently shot herself
deputies say she drove around for hours
with her son in the backseat to quote
freeze to death
the deputies found her took her to the
hospital where she was treated for her
injuries
she was later booked into jail
the former fiance of the mother of malia
davis wants to be released from jail
more than one year after the girl's
death a grand jury indicted darion vent
for evidence tampering in davis death
vince initially told police he was
attacked and the four-year-old was
kidnapped her remains were found a month
later
and he was arrested vince wrote a letter
to the judge asking to have his bond
reduced
it's now set at 90 thousand dollars he's
also ordered not to have contact with
the girl's mother
or leave the county new details are
emerging about the death of a young
mother in cincinnati
as her boyfriend is indicted for her
murder and her son remains missing
antoinette levy has the story
nyetisha lattimore has been described as
a loving mother to her three-year-old
son nilo
now lattimore's boyfriend is facing new
charges
in her death prosecutors say that
lattimore was stabbed to death in her
apartment
sometime on or about december 5th seven
days later
her body was found in a bag near a
bridge over the ohio river
the grand jury indicted desean brown on
charges of murder felonious assault and
gross abuse of a corpse
nilo's stroller was found nearby and he
remains missing
volunteer searchers scoured the area for
nilo last week
and over the weekend they found a black
bag that homicide detectives took into
evidence
but they did not find nilo we're out
here searching for nylo
a little boy and i'm a mom i'm a
four-year-old so
this means a lot to me and just praying
that we find him and
bring him home to his family we are
still looking for nylon lattimore
to date please understand that but
growing concern has risen through our
investigation
in interviewing of desean brown who has
been charged with the death
of natisha lattimore growing concern to
the point we feel
that this may this event with nylo may
involve
foul play if nilo isn't found by the end
of the week the volunteers will go out
and search for him again next
weekend desean brown meanwhile will be
arraigned on those new charges
next week for law and crime daily i'm
angenette levy
thanks angenet now terry while the
search for nilo continues deshawn was
indicted on five felonies including two
counts of murder
what's next after the indictment you
know they're going to be
a number of pre-trial motions we might
even get a
plea so we'll see what the defendant
does but then right after the indictment
and the various pre-trial
you know motions there'll be the trial
itself and we'll see what happens
now i know terry this is pretty much
reading tilly's but do you think if
deshawn knew where nilo was
that his lawyers may be advising him to
tell authorities maybe get a better deal
for him
you know i think desean brown does know
where nilo is and
if in fact he were to tell the
authorities about that
i do think he would get a better deal
and i'm hoping and praying
that they can find him alive it's been a
while though and so i'm thinking
that that might not be the case but for
the family's sake i
i hope it is now if convicted
what is brown facing well he's facing
life here you know this is
ohio and as you know they do have the
death penalty there
but the governor has suspended that
death penalty
indefinitely because he's rethinking the
lethal injection so for now
this is only going to be a maximum of
life but
if in fact he is convicted yeah of
course
that trial if it does go to trial is
some time away
maybe the prosecutor files the proper
paperwork to ask for the death penalty
maybe they don't maybe they continue
based on this moratorium as you said
um just initial reactions to this story
quickly terry what did you first think
when you're when this story broke
you know brian i think we might get a
plea here because when the story broke i
thought there's enough
evidence against this individual there
were witnesses etc
that i think he might get a plea so that
might be the best deal for everyone all
around
exactly now thank you terry and i want
to thank you all for joining us here at
law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you